so there's this fantastic Wikipedia list
descriptively titled Wikipedia : unusual
articles I just remembered as that
Wikipedia list it's a collection of
hundreds of articles about unusual
unexpected and unbelievable subjects no
matter what link you click it's bound to
be interesting for that reason every
week I'm going to click on a new link
and teach you a little bit more about
our amazing world maps are very hard to
make to create a map from scratch 1s two
years of fieldwork er analyzation of
satellite photos so plagiarism has
always been rampant among map makers
it's pretty easy just to redraw the same
geographical features from one map on to
a new map and it's hard to get caught
you are after all drawing the exact same
world so map makers came up with a way
to catch individuals stealing their data
this is Argyll tynin West Lancashire
England according to a 2009 screenshot
of Google Maps Argyll tin is a town it's
supposedly located between autumn to the
south and Ormskirk to the north the
problem is if you go to this site this
is what you find the Argyll tenue
paper towns are fake places that are put
on maps as copyright traps a map maker
can make up a place and if they see that
a competing map maker also has that town
on their maps they know that at one
point the competitor plagiarized their
info so in Argyll Tain's case the town
probably wasn't placed there by Google
Google gets their data from tella Atlas
who sources their data from other
mapping companies who in turn get some
of their data from other mapping
companies somewhere down the line
someone must have place Argyll tanaan
the map as a trap and its presence on
Google Maps was just a remnant of that
after the fake town gained widespread
media attention who were removed it from
their map and it has since been replaced
with a marker designating the spot as a
ghost town there are hundreds of other
examples of Paper Towns in New York a
spot north of Roscoe New York was marked
as the town of aglow by the general
drafting company in 1930 the name came
from an anagram of the cartographers
initials and appeared on numerous maps
since its conception in the 1960s a glow
showed up on a Ranma Canali map of the
region and thinking they had fallen into
their trap
Esso who had bought the map from the
general drafting company threatened to
sue McNally the suit was dropped though
when Rand McNally pointing that aglow
had actually become a real place
sometime in the 1950s locals opened up a
general store north of Roscoe New York
and after looking at an Esso map of the
region decided to call their store the
aglow general store there for making a
glow an official place the store
eventually went out of business and the
town is censuses appear for most Maps
but this is one instance where a fake
town
real a similar idea of Paper Towns has
been used in other domains in 2001 the
word equivalents appeared in the New
Oxford American Dictionary defined as
the willful avoidance of one's official
responsibilities that word was made up
as a copyright trap and it actually
worked
dictionary.com and gules dictionary both
added a listing for the word equivalents
possibly proving a level of plagiarism
among the online dictionaries
occasionally unintentional traps are
created that prove effective before they
created Apple Maps Apple was making maps
on a much smaller scale for iPhoto these
maps had no attributions and therefore
no one could be sure where their data
was from but there were some obvious
clues this screenshot of Apple's map of
Norwich shows an area of disorganized
roads in the Northeast if you look at
the OpenStreetMap map of the area you
can see that these rows are actually
trails in a park overlaying the Apple
map over the OSM map of the area you can
see how perfectly the suppose it road
and trails line up you can assume from
this that Apple took their map data from
Open Street Map and mistook the trails
for roads a few months after the release
Apple officially credit Open Street Map
for their contributions to the maps
confirming that they use OSM's data
so those are Paper Towns I hope you
enjoyed this week's episode I'll be back
next week to bring you more from that
Wikipedia list